foreign
it's night and day right now where the
uh having Brooke Jenkins as district
attorney has totally changed the the
morale of the police department and much
of the city itself and business owners
we still have a long way to go in the
tenderloin and other parts of San
Francisco where drug dealers are are
running a 24-hour open market but we see
on the horizon that that's going to
change very soon D.A uh Jenkins has
successfully prosecuted uh several drug
dealers and they are now secured in in
prison and uh we are we're excited that
she has turned the tide on the
prosecution of drug dealers
thank you
the thing though that we're having
problems with as a result of having just
the Bodine in for two and a half years
is that the police department has been
demoralized we are hundreds of officers
below what would be Optimum for uh
patrolling the city making the streets
safe so criminals even though they know
that if they are caught and arrested or
going to face a prosecution where under
Joseph Odin they basically were let out
with with barely a slap on their wrist
uh the difference is that San Francisco
as we see in other cities is still
grossly understaffed we don't have
enough police officers walking the beat
the lack of policing definitely is
taking its toll on San Francisco
businesses tourism and US residents here
you have
um a a crazy phenomenon of catalytic
converter thefts uh Brazen daytime
robberies of uh businesses and and homes
broken into with with the residents uh
there so we definitely do need to have a
reversal of the number of officers where
we we see more and more they are
retiring they are transferring
um that that is not a good Trend and I
think it's more than 500 that are needed
I've seen it as high as 800 a shortfall
of police officers and sfpd we also are
finding pushback from uh the police
commission itself the police commission
is a appointed committee that oversees
the police department and works
hand-in-hand with the uh the Board of
Supervisors our city council and many of
those individuals on the police
commission and our city council are
anti-cop and so that's another problem
it's not just the DA's office it's not
yours that we have a shortfall in police
officers but they're still today are
many individuals that are elected or
appointed in City Hall that are anti
police and that's where Advocates and
activists such as myself are also
targeting to try and reverse that
problem and and the attitude from the
police commission